[Musique]
quand je rencontre quelqu'un comme vous
tous aujourd'hui
eca s'est naturellement on se demande ce
qu'on fait dans la vie
j'explique que je suis photographe à
l'hôpital la réponse réflexe est
naturelle et génial tu photographies des
bébé à la maternité
là je dois dire que non je photographie
des patients et les opérations de
chirurgie maxillo-faciale tout ce qui
touche au visage
ça a le mérite de faire changer le sujet
de la conversation très rapidement car
on peut se le dire entre nous j'ai
introduit dans un contexte familier
confortable l'essence même de ce qu'on
ne veut pas voir de ce qu'on veut garder
invisible la maladie les accidents les
attentats la souffrance physique et
morale et surtout les conséquences
inimaginables de c'est indicible sur ce
qui nous caractérise comme rien d'autre
notre visage ce qui nous rend unique
finalement ce qui induit la
communication traduit notre être par le
verbal et le non verbal
je parle ici par exemple de philippe
écrivain journaliste dont le visage fut
déchiqueté par une balle d'ak à 47 à
charlie hebdo ne plus pouvoir parler ne
plus pouvoir s'alimenter ne plus être un
personnage public philips est rendu un
temps invisible au monde
dans la charge était trop lourde pour
lui le regard de l'autre inquiet
questionnant incrédule devient un
fardeau quotidien parce que l'autre
projet en lui ce risque que ça lui
arrive un jour mais au prix d'un
processus long et animé par des acteurs
invisible mais bien réel
les techniques de reconstruction
chirurgicale vont redonner un visage à
chaque patient redessiner une courbe une
ombre lui permettre de retourner à la
vie de tous les jours tout simplement
reconstruire l'identité pour recommencer
philippe dont je viens de vous parler
fera un livre de ce processus le lambeau
poignant et intime au point d'être
salués par la critique et les prix
littéraires renommée on parle ici de 22
passages en bloc opératoire dont très
opération pour sa mâchoire et certaines
comme celle du lambeau peuvent durer
jusqu'à huit heures c'est une micro
seconde qui fait passer de l'autre côté
des années pour se reconstruire une vie
qu'a basculé
j'imagine que vous avez ressenti cette
allitérations andreu qui caractérise
tellement mon travail que j'en ai fait
naturellement le titre d'une série
photographique captant l'invisible avec
comme ambition de l'exposer et d'en
faire un livre j'ai voulu faire
cohabiter des instants clés jamais
visible d'ordinaire et j'ai intitulé
cette série re les réécritures de la
chair vous voyez derrière moi une
première image parmi la vingtaine qui la
composent dans ce long processus de re
figuration la notion d'invisibilité
prendre toute son ampleur
il y a ceux qui se soustraient aux
regards les patients ce qui passe temps
est clair les chirurgiens et tous ceux
qui ne veulent pas voir
nous vous tout le monde eh bien c'est
exactement là à cette intersection des
temps et de tout ce qui se cache regard
que j'ai choisi de positionner ma
pratique artistique et je me suis dit
que j'allais en faire mon travail
alors oui je sais mais je vous explique
au départ c'est une part de fascination
et de fantasmes autour de la chair et de
la chirurgie que j'ai cherché à capturer
dans mes photographies de bloc
opératoire il ya une quinzaine d'années
l'acte se déroule que
soit là ou pas capter cette instance et
le faire exister le rendre visible dans
les blocs opératoires je me rend
invisible pour capturer le geste du
chirurgien cet instant particulier où
tout se met en place dans l'inconscient
collectif et les images télévisuelles et
cinématographiques ceux des salles
d'opération baigné dedans ou des actions
réalisées dans l'urgence mais on est
loin de la vérité dans cette danse
je découpe les séquences pour mettre en
valeur le geste du chirurgien et je
hisse ces moments au statut d'oeuvre il
en raffole
car les échanges avec les chirurgiens
que j'ai pu photographier m'ont appris
qu'ils ont un goût prononcé pour l'art
leur sensibilité à la peinture à la
sculpture ou à la photographie est
assumée et revendiquée
pourtant c'est sans doute parce que la
reconstruction du patient s'inscrit sur
des temps longs qu'au fil des années et
il m'a fallu des années mon sujet
d'étude a glissé de la technique
chirurgicale vers l'humain avec la
compréhension des enjeux polymorphe de
ces reconstructions
je parle ici de patients qui m'ont
confié ne plus accepter d'être
photographié depuis ce qui leur est
arrivé
ils fuient les appareils photo les
réunions de famille où on enregistre les
souvenirs en images
ils ne veulent pas qu'un seul souvenir
de ça existe des patients qui se rendent
invisibles au monde et autant à l'heure
où le self y est roi
le narcissisme la norme l'image de soi
omniprésente
lorsque je présente le projet photo aux
patients qui consiste donc à réaliser un
portrait de durant leur reconstruction
le contexte émotionnel et personnel est
toujours extrêmement complexe
le portrait que je vais réaliser
et de est souvent la première image de
cette nouvelle identité celle de la
réappropriation j'essaie d'être
l'étincelle qui leur donne envie de
remettre cette nouvelle identité au
premier plan alors même qu'ils ont le
sentiment de devoir rester invisible
tant que leur visage n'est pas réparé
avec cette photo leur statut change de
patients objet de bien modèle sujet
philippe dont je vous ai déjà parlé à
refuser longtemps d'être photographiée
le temps de se réapproprier son visage
avec le projet de l'exposition son
acceptation a été immédiate tant sa
confiance et entière il y a également à
damas qui après avoir vécu littéralement
l'enfer dans son pays existe maintenant
au grand jour grâce à une pleine page
dans le parisien le faisant apparaître
alors comme un homme de réseau et de
sagesse plus que comme un homme avec une
tête bizarre avec ce travail j'ai voulu
questionner le beau dans ce qu'on ne
veut pas voir et traiter ce beau avec
une rigueur esthétique presque canonique
utiliser l'art dans sa forme la plus
d'essentiel montrer pour questionner
j'utilise les codes du portrait de la
renaissance pour questionner davantage
notre faculté de re voir que notre
capacité de jugement avec ces anonymes
et leurs histoires singulières
si l'oeuvre d'art est fait pour être
regardé contempler qu'en est il de la
place du spectateur est dérangeant pour
vous avez vous détourner les yeux de
certaines de ces images ou au contraire
et de vous étonner par le charisme de
ses passions que trouvez pas qu'elle est
belle cette jeune femme est ce que vous
vous demandez quel a été son histoire
son parcours pour en arriver là où elle
en est aujourd'hui à quoi il ressemblait
avant se demande-t-on pourquoi on la
trouve belle l'histoire de l'art
occidental a toujours été hanté par
cette question du bo elle s'interroge
depuis toujours sur des formes de tabou
ce qui nous repousse et nous attire à la
fois mais la réalité quotidienne est
autrement plus difficile lorsqu'on est
la personne au visage différent pour eux
pose et dans ce cadre là était un vrai
défi
il savait qu'il était question d'être
regardé scruter jugé ils ont dépassé la
peur du jugement
et on peut dire que chacun s'est
largement dépassé les tirages en 2010
par un médecin en photographiant ces
patients je m'inscris dans leur parcours
de soins et du processus de re
figuration le portrait que je réalise de
ne marque pas la fin de leur
reconstruction
mais le début d'une certaine forme
d'acceptation qui est nécessaire au
rétablissement
l'invisibilité n'existe pas il ne tient
qu'à nous chacun de nous d'accepter ce
beau sens le questionner ou le juger
j'espère aujourd'hui vous avoir aider à
démystifier une partie des tabous autour
de la chirurgie et vous offrir un
nouveau point de vue sur ces gueules
cassées par la vie vous offrir l'idée
que le bo est partout je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]